big outing for joe ross he needs to turn
things around here yeah huge outing here
for joe ross fastball 93 miles per hour
off of starland castro
jesse winker aboard
uncertain swing on 94 away that's fair
castro long throw looked it into his
glove right on target to josh bell
not an easy play on a ball that wasn't
hit that hard and castro takes care of
his business a couple of reds stranded
early and the nats are glad that ball
did not hit the third base bag
fourth career start by hoffman the 28
year old right-hander 0-1 against cenets
for the 491 era oh look at josh bell
shift this he says and then ants have
two on
with one out on their first base hit now
the inning is up to sterling castro
there's a shot to left that's on a hop
to winker soto's gotta hurry the throws
way off line and castro delivers with
two outs to put the nats on top and
harrison spits on that one and now the
bases are loaded for alex sevilla
inside two-nothing nets
avila saw it all the way
and he gets his fifth rbi walking for
the ninth time
there he goes
pitch down
no chance for barnhart
this pitcher gave him no shot
and trey turner is now nine for ten
up misses away
soto walks again
and now out of 11 winners jeff hoffman
has walked five
well the full pin phone is ringing to
the cincinnati reds yeah they uh
well maybe there's something wrong with
him now he must have signaled something
to the dugout
because david bell's on his way out
steve bowman their head trainer
may be something going on where he can't
finish his delivery and he's done
well brett brought 35 years of age it'll
be his third appearance for the reds
two oh schwarber rolls it over to the
right side
india
oh he thought about going to the
shortstop with two outs i don't know why
and then he lost the play at first and
the bases are loaded
maybe a young player overthinking a
rather simple play
in the air to right
[Music]
now stianos
leave him loaded the reds have been
living out of his own
down
another base hit
harrison on the move barnhart's throw
looked a little late josh stays on he's
into second base
and the nats are two for two ripping
bags tonight
joe ross
with a chance to increase his lead joe
ross space head
drives in a run he's got to get to first
and he does
now the throw gets away
it bounces into the camera well then it
goes up into the seats and joe ross is
going to have an rbi hit
and he's going to go to second base
his weather apps first pitch oh my
goodness joe ross
look what you found a little backhand
for the first down here in the fourth
inning on tyler stevenson
don't you guys don't they work on these
plays in spring training
well he said he said he's a good athlete
look at this behind the back step
real smooth
okay
it's nice
he looked a little surprised that he
caught it too he said oh
nice play
so here's what happens after the three
hour three minute rain delay tonight at
205 tomorrow
this game which is now suspended will be
resumed with the nets coming up in the
bottom of the fourth
now he has a multi-hit game counting
last night and tonight they better get
this ball in quickly
holding the runner at third and there's
a play at second and he's out
and he knows it
jesse winker with a runner at third
tries to stretch it into a double and
andrew stevenson made things happen out
there to get the runner at second
yeah excellent job by him came up firing
no wasted movement on his feet footwork
but good slap tag here and people
probably wondering what jesse winker was
doing
but you can see here he's hustling out
of the box the whole entire way he had
two on his mind because he hit this ball
into the right center field gap but
stevenson
appropriately got up fired made a good
strong throw
right to second base
and right bobby right i mean you got the
national league leader in hitting coming
up
you're more likely to have success if
you just stick at first and third there
than being overly aggressive
and he fights one off
that ball's on the ground and it is rbi
number 26.
well last night he took a walk now he
gets a blue pit
and things looking up for trey turner
then actually four nothing
[Music]
right on cue
two strikes you want to let the ball
travel
this breaking ball from hendrix just and
really get at bat with the man on third
with less than two outs of driving the
run
big gap right center
second baseman in right field
and that's perfectly placed
no second baseman there and the nats
have a two run sixth inning to lead five
nothing
well there it is bobby said it two-hour
rbi
good job by josh bell to put this
splitter or change up in play
finds a hole not a picture perfect swing
but hit it where they ain't as they say
that's lovely
another nature getting it done with
singles
castellanos
into right center wave is on to third
for the reds first run suarez comes home
and they eat the relay the reds are on
the board it's five to
13 straight games with a hit for the
scalding hot nick castellanos the
back-to-back reds hits on opposite field
singles
winker did it castellanos did it
second longest hitting streak of his
career
payoff
is into right field base hit
winker scores station the station
advance
that is five hits in the eighth inning
for the reds who have clawed back within
three
now coming right in there with a
fastball down around the
lower part of the strike zone and that's
a good swing by barnhart you know you
made a good point john earlier that he
had a couple of really good spoil swings
max schrock did it last inning made the
pitchers work a little bit
farmer lifts it to right
soto
makes the grab tag in third castellanos
roars to the plate throw there not in
time
gets his left hand on the dish backside
over to third base shoots tyler naked
sac fly rbi a three-run inning it's a
two-run game i'll tell you juan soto
shows a pretty good arm right here gets
himself set makes it fairly close
but the odds of him catching cassiano is
not good at all and
just deep enough to score the runner
ground ball
castro
got it back popped up on him and the
nats win it
series back even
and a chance to win it tonight
and brett hands suddenly
is hot as a closer
yes throwing those strikes on those
heaters